okay so welcome the two of you today we
may have more come in and I am going to
ask both of you to participate in the
sense that this is a ask me anything
which is pretty much kind of an open
forum in some ways except I'm gonna go
through a couple of things that I want
to share with you specifically around
the issue of how to tell your story and
some hints on how to do that and that's
you tell me your tell me about yourself
question that often is asked in an
interview very first thing and one of
the big takeaways I want you to
understand is that that is not about
recapping your resume at that point this
is about storytelling and engaging your
audience and hopefully making them want
to put you on to the next step basically
so
as an introduction I will just give you
a little bit about myself so I'm located
in Portland Oregon I work with Udacity
as a coach I think I've met maybe
five hundred at this point Udacity
students since last year and from all
over the world I've been counting and
it's I think 43 countries at this point
and this is a question that often comes
up in how we can talk about ourselves
and and it's it's very difficult so
that's why I wanted to take it on as a
as more of a webinar exercise rather
than just in a coaching session and I've
been coaching for the last nine years or
so and have a background in presence
base coaching so I like I like people
being present that's pretty much what
that comes down to when we coach okay so
that's a little bit about me this is
what we're gonna go over today we're
going to talk about the elements that go
into right are you seeing the share
Michael by the way and and Addison
uh I so you don't see me I see you I'm
just wondering do you see my powerpoint
Cher oh yes yes okay just checking
so these are the things that we're going
to go over today exploring what are the
elements that go into your personal
brand so this will go beyond just
telling the story but things to consider
when you are creating a personal brand
which in a sense we all have as we
explore in life and then we're going to
go into practicing telling your story
and we'll get feedback feedback about
that okay so personal brand and Addison
I think I've unmuted you so you can
participate as well and whoever else
joins us we will we will have them join
and please interrupt as you will as well
so personal brand I just want to go over
this first to begin with
the first step in deciding what your
personal brand is is to determine and
prioritize your values and passions this
is goes to a deep sort of question of
who are you what do you think is most
important to you
what what has been most fun for you even
passions
you know passions are about it not just
things you're obsessed with but the
things you you have a sense of fun out
of and what's important about this first
step to get a sense of this is this is
the beginning of what you want to share
as far as your story goes it's not I
went to this school in that school and
and I had this job in that job and that
you know these are the experiences I had
what people want to know about and want
to connect with is who are you deep down
what cut what is it that drives you when
did you first get a sense of what your
passion would be actually for some
people it's when they're four years old
and they they problem solve for the
first time and realize there's these
marvelous things out there that they
don't understand but then they figure
them out and that starts a whole
lifelong obsession with problem-solving
so for you getting a sense of is that
really drives you mm-hmm
let's see I think everybody's coming in
automatically but I I'm hoping so it so
I think Mike has just joined us second
thing is to did find your key straight
traits and what I call this I call this
the spice um there was a woman that I
worked with years ago who was a cook and
she was trying to she was working on
this problem of tell me about yourself
tell me about your story and she didn't
really have much to say she just kept
saying that she was I'm a cook I'm
really good cook that's you know that
that's my experience in life and we
doubled it down a bit more and trying to
get to what is it that she was really
expert in why would I turn to her versus
three other cooks in front of me and
choose her from my restaurant and why
would I want her in the kitchen and
immediately she said well I
I know spice I am an expert in spice I
know exactly how spice is supposed to to
play with the palate basically and which
ones to use for which dishes somehow I
just know that
eat down so I like calling this your
spice because for her it was literally
about spice and the thing that made her
story come alive for you I don't know
what it is yet but this is this is a
question it's what it is that makes you
come alive what it is that that
distinguishes you if I have a panel of
people who have similar educational
background similar work experience to
you why do I turn to you what is it that
you are bringing that those people are
potentially not bringing I don't care
what they're bringing by the way I just
care what you're bringing and that you
can identify that and bear that image I
this does not to be superficial but this
is to be real we're all animals and we
all instinctively react to visuals and
to smells and when you go out there into
the world you are making a decision as
to how you want to present yourself and
are these you know what what do you want
to have come across by the way you are
addressing by the way you are smelling
also I bring that up because sometimes
that's something that people say no
that's cultural you know I wear perfume
I smell like like garlic whatever yes
but then you're making that choice and
know that some people will have reaction
to it and that this is something that
you're choosing to present and and know
that there could be a positive or
negative reaction to how it is you're
presenting yourself Steve Jobs is a good
example of a person who chose a look and
they just stuck with it so you didn't
have to wonder who he was in the room
because he always looked exactly the
same
maybe that's the type of thing you want
to choose a look where you're clearly
identifiable every time you walk into
the room we know who Michael is or who
Addison is because they look a certain
way
they keep they keep up their appearances
in a specific way so I'm not saying that
you have to be fancier you have to be
wear a t-shirt at all I'm just saying
this is a choice and make the choice
this goes to what your brand is and be
consistent about it
the defining your target audience us to
do with how you speak how you present
yourself depending on who you're
presenting and speaking to and knowing
that it's appropriate at times if you're
people speaking to people who are below
you in the workplace let's say we don't
have as much as experience as you do or
perhaps are in a younger group that you
may need to adjust how you are speaking
and how you are presenting yourself and
this is not about not being genuine this
is absolutely about being genuine but
it's also about being heard and knowing
that there are ways to speak and to
present yourself that might be more
appropriate for an older audience and a
younger audience or a more experienced
audience and a less experienced audience
either way so keep that in mind as well
the object of all of this personal
branding the object is for you to be
able to communicate well with others and
to be heard that your voice is heard and
that your there's nothing standing in
your way of that
so this this fourth one you know it
could be taken as oh you're telling me
to perform and you know act one way with
one group of people and another way with
another group of people and you know
that's not being genuine or that's
wearing a mask and and my response to
that is wearing masks all the time we
are all presenting ourselves in a
specific way to people and I'm just
saying let's be conscious about it let's
be conscious about it and it and be
clear about what your goal is and if
your goal is to be heard and to be seen
in some way make an effort to make that
happen
you guys hear me yeah I can hear you now
were you talking you're in now Addison I
can't see you but I can see but I can
hear you and and Addison interrupt at
any point as well and and if you have
any questions or fight me on it I just
find either way okay
so building your online presence I want
to give you an example actually of a
friend of mine from college I just
noticed this about and it's something
that I've always said is an important
thing to do and I just saw him doing it
which was fascinating so this is a
fellow who lived in Japan for many years
has been a journalist all over the world
but mainly focused on stories from Japan
that moved back to the United States
maybe I don't know five or six years ago
something like that and is doing a
career shift in his his career and
turning into a data analyst and so he
has started to put out there on LinkedIn
things that he's just interested dat'll
data visualizations basically that he's
interested in if it was one about birds
in fact and how birds are disappearing
from different areas so these aren't
even necessarily business-related ones
okay but what it
it's doing is the the ideas be the thing
that you want to be be a part of the
communicate the community that you want
to be part of host things comment on
things show like he did like a
visualization that he just made because
it was interesting and it shows off his
talents as a visual visual storyteller
basically this isn't about getting work
to be the thing that you are but
actually being the thing that that you
want to be does that make sense that's
stepping into it basically an online
your online presence having that be a
good part of it basically and one thing
to note and I've noticed this with the
different communities at Udacity some of
them meet on LinkedIn some of them meet
on Twitter I think it's the data
analysts that are very into Twitter if I
remember right but the one of the
questions you know as you move forward
in your careers like what community are
you a part of and where are they meeting
where are they having these
conversations is it in blogs you know or
is it on Twitter or is it on LinkedIn um
it's probably not on Pinterest or
Instagram but maybe it is I don't know
but the question is where are they and
you know the thought leaders and so on
where are they posting what are they
saying I have another friend who's a a
professor and you wouldn't think that
being a professor would lead you to
posting a lot on Twitter turns out
that's where the professor's are meeting
for whatever reason that's where they
they post and they get themselves known
obviously it forms and so on also but
not on LinkedIn on on Twitter so your
online presence be aware of what the
community is that you want to be a part
of and start presenting yourself as part
of it
and the last step that I want to for you
all to keep in mind is to not
necessarily reinvent the wheel for
yourself but look at the people that you
respect that are at the forefront of the
career that you are choosing to be in
where are they speaking how are they
presenting themselves
what sort of subjects are they bringing
up are they blogging for example um I'll
bring up the Steve Jobs again I don't
know he's just I don't particularly like
him but you know he's he's a good
example of a person that whose life was
sort of laid out you know for the public
to know about for the good and the bad
of it but he could be an example of
somebody that you might want to not it
but but see the choices that he made and
if that's an area that you want to be
and see if there are some choices that
you can make that are along the lines of
the people that have come before you
hold on one second okay first of all any
questions so far no no okay great okay I
want to go on to my next slide but I'm
having trouble there it is
okay
so I have a little format that I'd like
us to play with now this is not I don't
want you to look at this as this is how
I must speak about myself and this is
not a robot thing okay but it's it's a
form for us to play with and for us to
get to start to boil it down and I'm
going to do it first okay to give you
some sense of it but I want I want us to
actually play with this and you all to
tell me your story and then us too to
play with this and see how we can get a
good version of it out or at least get
the beginnings of a good version of it
out okay so in using this example here
I'm going to give you my story and and
but honestly when I do tell my story I
do say it somewhat like this when I do
it so i use my sense of humor and warm
personality for winning clients I'm
known for my intelligent and strategic
thinking using my experience as a
filmmaker and a storyteller I help
others tell their stories by providing
coaching advice career coaching advice
excuse me okay so that was my version of
telling that story that gave you some
sense of my background right
this is this was me talking to an HR
person for a career coaching job but
what I might tell them the question you
need to ask yourself is what would your
best friend say about you or your mother
what would they say about your teacher
or boss who has worked with you how
would they characterize you is one
question to ask yourself
another question I would say to ask
yourself and I didn't do this in this
one but I think it can be really
informative in starting to look at how
to tell this story about yourself for
whatever it is that you're doing now
when did it start when did the thing
that you want to do now or that you are
doing right now when did that kernel of
an idea come to you may have been when
you were four years old it may have been
at the end high school it may have been
last week okay but sing something told
you I need to go in this direction
there's something there for you
that moment may be a moment that you
want to share there may be something
about that moment that you want to share
so it's another thing to consider when
you're thinking about your story is what
was the impetus behind this I'm a big
believer in there are major thematics
that we have in our lives not not one or
two but there may be three or four
different thematics of how we've
approached life how we've looked at it
what we've done with our lives even and
we can be aware of the connectivity and
what we want to do in this personal
brand or this that's you know tell me
about yourself question is we want to
give people insight into at least one of
those themed attics
most probably the the somewhat
professional one but not necessarily so
if you're a marathon runner and your
thing is running marathons and you also
happen to be a coder if you tell me that
you've run all the major marathons in
the world and that running is an
obsession of yours I get a sense of who
you are even before you told me anything
about the coding I know what type of
work that goes into that I know what
type of obsession goes into that I get a
sense of who you are and yeah I like it
or I don't like it right but at least I
know what I'm dealing with so it doesn't
necessarily have to be from your
professional career that that you take
this moment or share something it could
be something from your very your
personal life but is exemplary of what I
can expect of you okay Michael oh yes
what I'm going to ask you the question
oh yeah I'm gonna ask you to tell me
about yourself and you can choose to
answer this like I li I just laid out
what we have up on the board right or to
choose them any way you like
except that
imagine that I am somebody who first of
all has in front of me your resume so I
know I don't know but pretend I know I
know where you went
I know I know what your educational
background is I know something about
your professional experience at least
I've spent you know 10 seconds looking
at it I have a general feeling you're
not X or Y okay so you don't need to
summarize that for me but you do need to
tell me about you enough so that I feel
like oh he's an interesting fellow maybe
I want to have him do it first of all
what do you do what is your your job
right now I'm tutoring a test prep a
math test prep in math and what is your
ambition to be a data scientist and a
commentator on current events and maybe
get involved in marketing okay so Who am
I I'm going to be an HR person in data
science or a a podcast producer well I'd
like to get a job and so I think
probably a data analyst okay data
analyst HR person okay because it dads I
said it's important to know who your
audience is and that's a vastly
different audience
they podcast producer who wants to know
if they want to have you on the show and
do commentary or I want to I want to
trust that my business is going to go
forward basically with this type of
analysis that you will do it'll give me
the type of tools I need to move my our
business forward okay so so let's play
the data analyst one
in a sharper I have a job in data
analysis you look like you're qualified
for it enough so that I picked up the
phone okay and I'm gonna ask you Michael
tell me about yourself
I'm a teacher and a social scientist and
I've I've used well I've done lots of
things to turn words into the numbers to
make predictions or gain insights of
behavior mainly in academia and I've
also taught all over the world from
Afghanistan to Japan to Mississippi
other places exotic exotic foreign
countries but anyway and I played I
played jazz guitar actually and one time
quite serious about it
but now I'd like to I'd like to yeah
start with a sequel analyst job and just
get very good at making basic
visualizations and sequel queries okay
stop now
yeah you can stop now so I'm gonna I'm
gonna give you some feedback for what I
heard okay so I hear you're a teacher
you're a communicator is one thing okay
so you know how so one of the things
that has been important to you is
communicating whatever it is that you're
teaching basically that's part of the
essence of and that you pursued at one
point we're very serious about a jazz
career I jazz as a part of mathematics
to some degree that it is an artistic
area but that there is behind it as well
to be a good improviser you know you
need to know the structure you know and
and then you can play within the
structure of it I want to hear a little
bit more how you enjoy and you've played
with this a little bit but I want to
hear a little bit more how you like
bringing insight to people being
- bring the connectivity to people
basically through data through the data
analysis and that you have done this
type of work in a sense through how you
communicate with your audience whether
it be in jazz or it be in teaching
hmm well I you know I given a number of
presentations at conferences based on
the idea that you can get quantitative
information out of verbal documents and
performances and use that to predict or
at least explain in behavior great I I
did that in my dissertation about like
it's about 15 years ago now
and I I got quantitative information
about out of congressional records and
was was one of the first people to do
that actually using Perl interesting an
old programming language I don't think
it's used as much anymore anyway so able
to tell that your story like being able
to tell this person that you have had
this al be exaggerated a little bit okay
but you've had this obsession for a long
time of being able to take words and
tell stories out of them with numbers
that no that has seen you through
through both teaching your dissertation
even your jazz work but that could you
know being able to create unique
insights through the the communication
of language to numbers basically telling
that that that's where I would focus so
you have a very unique story and an
interesting I want I just want it
brought together
well I I use my facility with words and
with numbers to analyze human speech and
and written speech in order to gain
insights about behavior and and I'd love
communicating those insights to people
especially in person I I just love an
audience and I find my personality and
my my sense of humor and my sense of
well that you can any idea no matter how
complex can be visualized and if you
visualize it properly you can
communicate it it presents some of these
findings so I'm gonna add one thing to
your thing first of all that's better
and and that that was I like that
more that that told a story to me about
remember I'm HR person looking for a
data analyst right so I want I want I
that way one question I would ask for
you is I could you tie in perhaps either
something in the past that has brought
value to others when you're doing this
or the type of value you want to bring
to me you know in where you're going now
in the future basically with regard to
this ability to change words into you
know take words and quantify them and
communicate with them well you know the
chiefly the value I brought was to other
political scientists in well in
understanding policy change most
political scientists the political
decisions as you know bare-knuckled
course trading and based on firm
interests and material interests and not
on ideas and I was able to show in my
dissertation and in in other works
people changing their thinking before
where they changed their behavior and
their decisions about public policy and
therefore to show that you know ideas
and speech are an independent realm and
not just a justification for things that
people want to do based on the chair of
interests and so I think I think we can
use quantitative analysis of human
language to get at the world of ideas
which has its own independent and
independent principles of movement and
that can help us understand human
behaviorism as policy makers and as
consumers ok good
I would I the first part of it getting
too much into the political science
aspect I think I'm again HR person data
analyst a little too far afield the end
of it I thought was more grounded in
making sense to me as an HR person going
okay so he's a good guy for bringing
insights to things that people might not
notice the insights in well ok so I
would steer you a little more in the the
end of that direction
ok ok yeah so I'm gonna take the take
you off the hot seat for a second
Michael ok Addis thank you
I'm gonna put you on the hot seat can I
use your volume on oh I don't hear yes
there you are ok good so Addison I want
to try the same thing with you the so
first of all just tell me basically what
is your background and what it is that
you are heading towards ok my major is
chemical engineering so I used my
critical thinking and the statistical
unless
for well I try to transfer to the data
analyst also just like Michael okay good
yeah currently I've been working as
accounting assistant just try to get my
straight white to get it to the dork
okay and I'm known for mathematics I
guess and I'm using mastery as them to
provide insight and also interesting
interest factors when I was a chemical
engineer I always study although he's to
historical scientists what do they use
and to check if it's a face ability with
disability for this medical or so and
the one I try to do data analyst I guess
I can use all the data from the history
and they try to keep insight about the
future ok good Edison the end of it you
got into it no I'm serious so now now
we're getting into what it is that drove
you in at being a chemical engineer and
then what distinguished you as a
chemical engineer that that you that and
that same thing distinguishing you now
so you interesting that Michael also has
a sense of history in that way but you
you like getting into the history of
things you know and you know not just
accepting the numbers as they are but
how did the numbers get there yes and
going deeper into it and that you you
believe that you gain insight from the
deeper knowledge and and asking
questions that haven't been asked yet of
that material to to gain insights
okay that's correct okay so that's great
I that's the story I want to hear I have
a one question like before I go to of
those interview I don't know how deep
you can combine your personal interest
with your professional expertise so like
yeah
is why I want you to go personal okay I
do so it's hard for okay so imagine that
you have had we've done this eight times
today ten times today okay do you think
I'm remembering you by the yeah hey no I
I can't bring one thing I think gonna
make you guys remember me I was trained
for marathon professionally five years
ago oh really yes and well the reason
why I quit one is because I enjoyed
myself for the other reason why because
I look at all the day that I have I
don't think I can be successful in this
field and I have about a year of
training data with a professional team
perfect it's okay I think I think it
totally is okay because first of all the
obsession that many marathon runners
have with all the data and and like
figuring out what if I have a piece of
bread now versus two pieces of bread
later what difference is that going to
make my energy levels and how when do I
crash by it is a amount of data that
marathon later marathon runners deal
with in order to succeed it's not only
finish but to do their personal bests
and that you looked at it that way a
more conscious of how you are looking at
it and and able to apply it is
potentially potentially and interesting
for you to tell but I'm I'm saying
basically is that if you think about
somebody having this conversation with
at least 10 people in a day and I know
that when I'm coaching to be totally
honest if I coach eight people in a day
I have no clue who I talk to in the
morning I can barely remember I have to
look at the notes I have to go like who
was this what story was this I can't
[Music]
unless it was something really
interesting and extraordinary and your
jazz thing is really different your
marathon thing is really different
I will remember both of you you're both
data analysts so I forgot that already
okay
Oh what am I gonna remember about both
of you two hours from now when I come
back home again that's what I'm gonna
remember you want to tap into that thing
that people are going to remember and
give it to you who cares if you
introduce yourself as like I'm just a
great data analyst and I went to school
for it and I learned and I'm good I give
insights to people they like it
I okay fine it's not memorable speaking
to his data analysts no ten times a day
so I'm looking for something from you
Addison that distinct and so you're at
your question was how much personal do I
have to give versus professional I would
say you give as much personal as will
give me a sense of who you are and and
and be somewhat a little open and and
tell me something that's a little bit
memorable about you I see well I guess I
can bring up another story after I quit
my marathon training I become a foodie
I eat around all over the time and it
gave really good suggestions about the
restaurant considering about environment
how much money you want to pay like your
budget or what kind of food do you want
to eat and many of my friend they take
my suggestion very seriously and they
want to ask me okay this is my first
date where should I go where should I
bring this person to go okay I want to
go to the hiking near this area do you
have any options for us because I really
want to
wait okay with the marathon stuff well
you were you that connector type person
when you were starting to do the
marathon also were you collecting
information and sharing it and and
asking for information from people also
was that the yes okay we do have the
sheet together spreadsheet together to
analyze each runners behavior including
weather including weather whether you're
eating what the weather is like like do
you behave better in the morning or in
the afternoon yes like sleeping schedule
do you need to have to get a better
running result so what would you
describe this as Addison I see it as
very similar things whether you'd say it
is the food example or the marathon
example I see a similar behavior here in
a similar obsession perhaps in breaking
down the the human existence into
quantifiable things that that can be
mastered and and information that can be
shared I see that you're doing that in
in two different realms he doesn't care
what realm you share do you know saying
but it's about expressing some of that
passion I see and how I do believe I do
believe everything and everybody can
master master certain of techniques or
skills as well as they follow following
certain broad as long as you just just
break down to the smaller piece and you
just accomplished one by one everybody
can be a master that's how I believe it
and that's what I believe
wonderful I think I think that's
interesting I think that distinguishes
you from Michael
no no Michaels Michaels good at other
things
weaving you're both up for the same data
analyst job and
I want to get a sense of you know what
I'm getting out of Michael is going to
be different than what I'm getting out
of Addison okay and I can tell this now
from both of your stories that I am
getting different things out of you
Michael based on some of his past
experience being a communicator through
music and through teaching you know and
an academician basically and that being
his thing you being obsessed with how
you how you you know break human
behavior down into its my nudist
elements and and how that you can use
that to communicate with people and
they're just different stories and
different in different focuses and tell
me something about both of you
that is not about where did you go to
school and what was the the coolest last
thing you do on your job although we
could have gone in that direction as
well for both of you any questions about
this I feel I don't know I I feel the
you know teaching Afghanistan was my
most fulfilling experience and it but it
was it was teaching well I was teaching
English mainly it taught some political
science I'm not sure how it relates to
being a data analyst and I feel like I
feel like my my my passion leads me to a
data scientist job analyzing talk and
speech but my qualifications my level of
preparedness you know kind of leads me
to an an SQL job with you know making
some visualizations I mean I went
through the data scientist course at
audacity and got a nano degree in it but
I you know I just really don't think I'm
gonna be prepare
for competing for those jobs yeah as far
as competing for the jobs go
you know what Udacity does and
regardless of Udacity what needs to
happen basically to make you competitive
or jobs that are a career shift for you
and both of you it's a career shift is
about doing more projects yourself if
giving you some projects that you can
put on the resume there are a few other
ways for you to get projects on the
resume freelance work is one way
internship possibly is another
open-source is another and volunteer
work is is the fourth that I know of
those are four different ways for you to
collect more experience doing
visualizations and doing data analysis
work that are because what you're trying
to do on your application forms is
you're trying to go an excellent
argument that you are a good match for X
whatever X is and so everything on that
application form
first of all key words have to be really
appropriate to whatever the job is that
you're applying for
that may be de-emphasizing some things a
lot and emphasizing other things and the
second thing is that the achievements
that you're showing off about are the
appropriate types of achievements
basically so yours is a communication
thing and your background just some
degree is about communication maybe
somewhat about visualization I'm not
sure those are those are things that are
desired in a data analyst job that you
have that ability to do that and you
check that by looking at a job
description and seeing what it is
they're looking for and then those are
things that you emphasize in your
package and as far as the projects go
what's good about them
is that you can put you know the
languages that you used meaning sequel
or whatever it is because yes they are
need to know that you are proficient and
that they do not want to be training you
as you come in you know they want that
you can be up and running basically and
so that you have proficiency in these
languages that are necessary basically
to communicate data and so the projects
are a way to emphasize that in your in
your LinkedIn profile in your resume as
well well that's very helpful I I have
to teach a student in a couple of
minutes here because I'm I'm a tutor as
your I want to thank you and thank you
for joining I'm gonna I'm gonna make use
of this and I'm probably going to be
bothering you during the next couple
months for more advice bother bother
away okay thanks androgen thanked by
Allison so Addison do you have any other
questions as we'll be ready in a few
minutes anyway yeah yes Oh first
questions do you always on this training
session every like every week no so I
did it once before and I didn't record
it and I said oh let's do it again
basically and we had many people before
but this specific training is one that I
have only done twice now it's something
I do in coaching sessions though uh you
know when when we get to that point of
practicing for interviews this is things
that that I work on do you have any
contact way so I can you know contact to
you a person or either any other surveys
yes I can find my cursor
I'm going to send you the email address
thank you very much
yeah and so and I'm one of the coaches
at Udacity mm-hm and that's me and oh
you know I people I meet people every
week mm-hmm one on one situation and be
happy to give you any sort of coaching
that you might like
individually I think the next webinar
that I'm doing is in August and I think
it's going to be around graduate school
or upskilling I see oh yeah you know
think I not off the top of my head right
now I'm sorry I can't remember exactly
what it was but but it's in August and
it will be on the Udacity calendar um
and they'll be they'll be advertising
that a few weeks in advance I will make
sure I check that that would be lovely
I would love for you to see you again
and have you join yes and also another
question is like whenever I go to other
interview are always afraid I don't have
enough to provide especially when it's
outside so what do you mean enough to
provide tell me what tell me a little
more about that like when you say like
especially your introduction session
it's like by providing blank so because
I guess because it do my career change
so I don't think I'm a de quit for the
job so there - I have two responses to
that one is imposter syndrome is a real
thing okay and I you can feel like
you're not adequate for the job and
there may be truth in that and there
also may not be truth in that okay some
of it can just be insecurity about
having not done it exactly before and
everybody has that and most everybody
has some sort of impostor syndrome which
is the feeling basically that
good enough until until you've mastered
it basically until you know you've
mastered it and then you're good enough
and then the next thing is you're not
good enough for I mean it comes back
again so so what get into a little bit
more with you I think is you know how
much of it is that feeling like it's I
haven't mastered it yet therefore I'm
not first of all if you've totally
mastered whatever it is you're going for
job wise it sounds like it probably
isn't a very interesting job that's very
true
you're kind of done with it already you
know so you don't really want a job that
you are a total master of you want you
want to keep evolving as a person and
keep learning and you keep expanding
what you've participated in in life and
that's why you're applying for a job not
just for money but for the experience of
it and so I think the thing to focus on
when you're going in for a job and this
is why I wanted to get to some of the
heart of what distinguishes you from
others
okay is you are bringing certain value
and values to them certain abilities to
problem-solve
for you what's interesting is you like
problem-solving in a wide variety of
areas from food to marathon running from
chemical engineering to data analysis in
a business this is you are very engaged
in whatever it is you take on and you
like going deep
that's all you got a that's a really
good point I never thought about it
Andrew you're so amazing no no but that
that's it you can't tell them I know how
to problem solve problem solve your one
problem that you can't even tell me what
the problem is because this is an
interview we can't do that you know so
what they're buying into and what you're
selling is you know do you have the
personality it and some of the
experience and and the drive to bring
them value for their investment in you
basically if you believe it they'll
believe it that's part of it too I
always try to hide it every interview I
was always very nervous but always make
sure I try to hide it at my best so it's
it it I think that the balance is it's
not it's sort of like it's not showing
off okay but it's like if you were a
salesperson a you had a shop right yes
if you are selling something under a
paperback and saying it cost $10 but
it'll be exciting I trust you but I'm
not gonna show you what it is and I'm
not even gonna tell you much about it
but trust me you'll like it when you get
it and then you have the same
salesperson show this wonderful plant
that's in the bag okay that you don't
have to water much at all and is is
going to produce a wonderful fragrance
and there's this plant in the bag and
you're like this cost the same amount by
the way this may be in your bag would
you like this then I can go well yeah
yes or no the other way I've you haven't
you've hidden
away yourself and I don't know what I'm
buying and I don't know if I want to buy
it or I don't want to buy it and maybe I
don't want to buy it maybe you put
yourself out there and you say oh my god
I'm a plant and I smell like this and
they go oh my god I don't want a plant
that smells like that okay at least it
was true and it wasn't a guess it wasn't
a game of of you're wondering what
you're getting surprise make people
excited so you don't need to show
everything no no you don't need to show
everything but you do need to not be in
a paper bag where you're get making it a
absolute guest job I don't know if I'm
getting a plant I don't know if I'm
getting a bag of candy you know you're
telling me it's good but I have no idea
what what it is no mystery is good in
some things okay in in this case I'm not
saying reveal your entire life and
expose yourself on every level possible
I'm saying choose what it is you want to
reveal and reveal something that is
memorable and genuine that's probably
one of the best lesson I learned
everything this year no so glad that you
have a lot to listen I love I like I
love the stories you've told already
about what you've done to do with the
foods in the and the marathon stuff you
definitely have value to give to people
and and and a marvelous thing for you to
tell and so I would just let people know
what it is
whichever one thank you very much so I
hope ya join again we're um I just
forgot there is something that you can
join in on every Tuesday mm-hmm haven't
asked me anything session at udacity at
nine o'clock in the morning Pacific time
I mean you're located but this is a time
nine o'clock in the morning and I'm on
there sometimes other coaches are on
there and it's literally just a okay
this is the this is the challenge I'm in
right now let's talk about this it's can
be very interesting well know that we'll
be there
okay great very good meeting you Addison
thank you for joining today
thank you for your coaching it was very
informative okay thank you have a great
Bank thank you
you